من علي تتمتع بالافضليه تعلم الجيوش ان
قدراتها الناريه الجويه تقطع بها عاده وقت
الحرب نصف المسافه نحو النصر اوكرانيا
فهمت ذلك مبكرا ليس من شك في ان ما تلقته
من اسلحه الغربيه حتى الان له كفاءته في
الميدان غير ان تبلور هجومها المضاد على
القوات الروسيه سيحوجها لاسلحه اكثر تطورا
وفاعليه
وتلك حاجه تزداد مع اداء الحربي الروسي
اخرج ضخمه من نطاق سيطرتها بحسب تاكيدات
موسكو
لا يسلم الرئيس الاوكراني بحسم الروس اطول
معارك حربهم على بلاده ولعله مطمئن بعد
اقرار حزمه جديده من المساعدات العسكريه
من واشنطن تصل قيمتها الى
375 مليون دولار
لكن اكثر ما يسعد زيلينسكي هو تاكد
حصولكييف في وقت ما على مقاتلات اف 16
الامريكيه
خلال اجتماعي مع الرئيس زلينسكي وكبار
الموظفين اثر ختام اجتماعات قمه الدول
السبع قلت ان الولايات المتحده وشركائها
سيبداون في تدريب الطيارين الاوكرانيين
على الجيل الرابع من المقاتلات ومن بينها
طائرات اف 16 من اجل تعزيز قدره سلاح الجو
الاوكراني وكجزء من التزام طويل الاجل
لمساعده اوكرانيا على الدفاع عن نفسها
يامل الاوكرانيون في ان الطائرات الاف سته
عشر ستغير مسار المعارك لمصلحتهم
مقاتله الصقر المهاجم كما تسمى ايضا
يستخدمها نحو 28 جيجا عبر العالم يبلغ وزن
الواحده منها ثمانيه الاف وستمئه
وبمقدورها ان تحمل خمسه الاف كيلو جرام من
الاسلحه والذخائر اما سرعتها القصوى في
2220 كيلومترا في الساعه متى ستحصل كييف
على هذه المقاتلات كيف ولايه غايه يقول
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي
ان الرئيس بايدن لم يتخذ قرارا بشان تقديم
تلك الطائرات من مخزونات الولايات المتحده
وان الحديث هو على ان يقدمها طرف ثالث
لاوكرانيا اما عن قيود استخدام الاسلحه
الامريكيه في اوكرانيا فيوضح السولفان
انها تقتصر على عدم استخدامها داخل حدود
روسيا وبالتالي فبمقدور اوكرانيا ضرب
الجيش الروسي داخل حدودها المعترف بها
وشبه جزيره القرم جزء منها قد يعطي ذلك
لمحه عن نطاق هجوم اوكرانيا المضاد
المنتظر
لكنه يكشف عن حرص حلفاء كييف في عمومهم
على عدم خروج الامور عن السيطره دون
استباق الاحداث يجري التركيز الان على
تدريب الطيارين الاوكرانيين على استخدام
الجيل الاحدث من المقاتلات الغربيه
بريطانيا التي تبدا العمليه على الارجح
خلال هذا الصيف توافقت مع دول غربيه على
تزويد كييف بالقدره الجويه القتاليه التي
تحتاجها
وعدت زيلينسكي ايضا بتسليم جيشه صواريخ
بعيده المدى وتلك بحسب خبراء عسكريين
ستمثل تحديات جديده صعبه للدفاعات الروسيه